hey you watching this uh Harry and Megan
uh it's been painful they come off like
such whiny [ __ ] I gotta tell you man
Howard Stern isn't holding back when it
comes to his feelings about Prince Harry
and Meghan markle's new Netflix
docu-series and it's safe to say he's
not a fan I will say what's on my mind
and sometimes that will rub people the
wrong way is you know that's my whole
career the radio personality weighed in
on Harry and Megan on his Serious XM
show Monday when those two start whining
about wearing wet it's just very weird
to watch two people who keep screaming
we wanted our privacy and then what is
their special that they put out on
Netflix
showing you them where and their kids
and their life it's like it's like the
Kardashians except boring this is a
couple who've been so fiercely
protective of their privacy and yet here
they are invading their own privacy by
putting those very private lives right
in everyone's living room and when ET
chatted with royal expert Katie Nichol
she revealed that's the sentiment across
the pond I think most people over here
are thinking you left Britain because
you didn't want the glare of the media
and yet here you are courting the
biggest streaming Giant on the planet
it's seems so hypocritical you want to
be left alone but then you sell a
special on Netflix where do you go with
this is this your career talking about
how humiliated you were being part of I
don't know living in a castle it looks
pretty terrific to me yeah like I said
Howard not a fan but he's not the only
one Harry and Megan documentary I found
it a little bit boring Bethany Frankel
gave her two cents on Tick Tock it felt
like this entire documentary was about
how famous we are if you're being
trolled by the media the royal family
gave you the advice to say nothing
because that's the advice that most very
famous people are given if you add
gasoline to a fire the fire blows up
even bigger and while Bethany isn't
dishing out rave reviews for The Duke
and Duchess of Sussex Gail King said she
couldn't wait to tune in during a stop
by Watch What Happens Live do you give a
damn about Prince Harry and Meghan
markle's new docu series yes I can't
wait yes yes you can't wait wait yeah
she told me she would never do a reality
show but yeah yeah it's not a reality
show that's called a reality it's not
it's something and Issa Ray who was a
guest on Megan's archetypes podcast told
E.T she was ready to hear what the
couple had to say that's how the trailer
the trailer was oh I was like they're
about to go in so I will um I will check
it out Marin Morris proved she's also
team Harry and Megan coming to Meg's
defense against the haters this profound
hatred and annoyance at Meghan Markle
specifically mostly coming from women I
have to say people are saying like oh a
woman should never take a man away from
this family that's all that this is
um have you seen this family Volume 2 of
the docu-series drops Thursday and a new
teaser promises we'll see more of that
Family Feud we're happy to lie to
protect my brother they were never
willing to tell Richard protect us so
how does the Royal Family feel about the
docu-series I've spoken to senior
Palisades who said they are reluctant to
comment unless there is anything
damaging
untrue or defamatory in this donkey
series they really don't want to be
drawn into it it's a case of keep calm
and carry on
[Music]